Let's talk about Lily Phillips,
because I don't know what the big fucking problem is.
If you watch the documentary and listen to what she is saying.
Not what he says, what she says.
She's like, I'm super excited to do this. I can't fucking wait.
Come to find out the hundred in a day was practice for the thousand.
Thousand has always been in the plans.
This is like, you know,
a fighter, you know,
this is like working up the ranks.
She's excited to do this.
Every single one of those guys got a hock to a moment of his own
by her own. Like she wanted to
the. The only negatives you hear are she'll say,
I'm so excited, and then he will,
in his documentary style, say,
oh, I could sense the nervousness.
All the nerves and fear
and anxiety that you're hearing are coming from him.
She asks him in the beginning of the documentary,
are you kinky? Do you do sexy things?
Or, you know,
are you into anything? Like,
he's like, oh, god, no,
no, no,
no, no, no.
He's like, as vanilla as they come.
Seems like it, too.
So the documentary was done through his eyes,
so of course
it seems like she's so fucking anxious and nervous and scared.
That's what he. No,
every. Anytime she said she was excited,
he's like, oh,
I could sense her fear. He even says, oh,
I bet she didn't think about condoms and She's like,
yeah, no,
we thought about condoms. Did you think about testing?
She's like, yeah, no,
we've asked them to get tested and send us a screenshot of their tests.
Like, he's the one that's making it seem worse than it is.
She's fully fine. She's great.
At the end of the day, when she does start to cry,
she's mad at the dudes that are being disrespectful to her.
She made it very clear, don't finish in my eyes.
She said that she would tell them multiple,
multiple, multiple times,
what do they do? They go right ahead and go right for the eyes.
She asked dudes to like, okay,
we gotta be done. And they would, like,
guilt trip her and be like,
oh, you're not gonna make me finish.
So the part that she had a problem with was the men's disrespect.
It wasn't.
It wasn't the event. She liked it.
She enjoyed it. And then in the TMZ interview she did after,
where she talks about when she cries,
she's like, no,
I'm crying because I just had this,
and I did have an intense day,
but then now I got a camera crew in my face,
and they're all in my shit.
Like, I think she's very gently trying to be like,
he's kind of a dick. I don't think he.
He put his personal spin on that to make it seem worse.
She likes it.
There are people who like it.
You don't. Have to want that much sex.
But there are people who do.
She is a creator. She's the one.
She produces it. It's.
It's the website where she gets to have full control.
Nobody's making her do this.
I don't know why people are, like,
so fucking up in arms over this.
She is okay with it. You can be okay with it.
You don't have to participate,
you don't have to watch it.
And you also don't need to put a negative spin on it when it's.
She is.
She's got a great relationship with her family.
What is the fucking problem?
There's no fucking problem.
No fucking problem whatsoever.